[Music]
darren brown's
specials on netflix are nothing short of
fascinating
they are what happens when someone who
is obsessed with human behavior instead
of choosing a career path in psychology
or psychiatry
decides to become an entertainer and
it's that obsession
that i wanted to tap into so i could
better understand
what it takes to be happy this
is a bit of optimism
it's very nice to meet you i have to say
oh well very nice
very very nice to meet you you and i are
both
interested in happiness
yeah but not the pursuit of it
which is ironic yes it's one of those
big
nouns which is better off living
as a verb as something active rather
than just this sort of
thing because the moment you see it as a
thing you start to think well
i'm entitled to it or it's something
that other people have and i don't or
it's
some kind of birthright or it's
something you're going to know when you
achieve it and all of those which
turn out not to be true i think it's an
activity isn't it something you're
constantly grasping at yeah
you maybe hold on to it for a second and
then it leaves i like this idea of happy
as a verb
to happy so happy yeah i i like that
yeah i i happy with my friends this
afternoon it was really fun
i think generally we should unpack nouns
into verbs as much as possible because
life is
complex and messy and all those nouns
are
us trying to reduce complex and messy
things to something
you know that our ego can neatly stack
away and
move on and we obviously need to do that
in order to navigate this strange world
but
every now and then unpacking those
things
particularly when it comes to partners
and relationships you know that's really
important isn't it not to just
see them as a kind of a a thing that is
you know contained
and you've worked that out and you can
move on as much as you can lean in
the mystery of another person no i
really like this idea i talk about this
in terms of corporate values
yeah you know where companies put their
corporate values on the wall and they're
all nouns
you know integrity innovation honesty
you know and you can't walk into
someone's office and say
little more innovation today please
steve you know it doesn't work that way
what am i supposed to do yeah and so i
i'm always advocating that
values should be written as verbs
because you want to do them
yeah you know so it's not honesty it's
tell the truth
it's not integrity it's do the right
thing it's not innovation it's look at
the problem from a different
angle those i can measure those i can
hold people accountable to
and those are doable things and you can
demonstrate improvement
even and so i really like this idea of
happy as a verb but even relationships
i'm girlfriending and i'm boyfriending
rather than this is my
girlfriend or this is my boyfriend yeah
that it is a job that i do
i boyfriend you know this is something
it's an activity
and it takes a lot of work and i'll
never be perfect at it yeah and it also
gets over that
you know that thing of like can you
should you change your partner so you
know you end up with this
conflict one person says if you'd love
me you you know you wouldn't want to
change me and then the other person's
going well why wouldn't i want to change
you and help you become a better person
but
part of the solution i think to that
conflict if you see this person
as an ever-changing evolving
person like a verb like if you kind of
denounce them if you just remember that
they are
an ever-evolving mystery then suddenly
you can love them for what they are
as somebody that is changing and
evolving
but doesn't someone have to see
themselves as evolving also
i mean this is an interesting question
can someone who sees themselves in
evolving date someone and have a
successful relationship with someone who
who doesn't see themselves as evolving
like don't you either have to both be
stagnant or both be evolvers to have a
successful relationship
that's a tricky one isn't it that's
that's kind of the task of life i'm
50 next year and i'm kind of aware now
of
very much i think it's particularly in
that second half of life that
we've probably had this whole project
for the first half of life
of you know ambition and trying to stake
our claim in the world and that's sort
of an axis between the ego between
ourselves
and the world and you kind of you do
that you slay your dragon and then you
have to rescue the princess the second
half of life then seems to be more about
serving something bigger perhaps or
digging more into a sort of a
relationship between the ego and
the self finding out more like what were
you supposed to be before the demands of
the world kind of distracted you you
know you spend the first half of your
life
kind of pursuing these trying to stake
your claim in the world and then i think
i think you really do become aware of it
after a certain point that that goes
so far and then you do need to evolve
there is a kind of
a shift that needs to happen i agree
with a caveat which is i'd completely
agree that
in the latter stages of our lives it
seems that we want to
pursue something bigger that we want to
leave legacy these kinds of words are
used but i don't think it's a condition
of age in the sense that the first half
is for this part of our life and the
second half of the is for that half of
our life
i think it's when we reach the middle
age
when we reach the second stage of our
lives we just become more aware
of our own mortality and then we start
asking ourselves the question
well was my life worth living because i
think young people are ambitious because
they're not yet thinking
they don't have the same sense of their
own mortality facing them and so
ideally why can't a 21 year old be
concerned about their legacy
and be concerned with living with
purpose living on purpose
why not start young but to your point
for some reason it only seems to occur
to us when we reach milestones like 50.
yeah
yeah i've never had any ambition of any
sort well i mean i'm 49 so yeah a few
years ago sort of early
early 40s i really got into the works of
the stoics
and my normal day job is you know
i've had a 20-year career in the uk with
a sort of strange evolution of what
began as magic and hypnosis and has now
become these giant
psychological experiments that i put
people through and i also have a stage
show that i tour with i was
just managed to squeeze in a broadway
right actually before um
before everything just disappeared up
there so i i've
sort of tried to kind of move it into a
different area one
strange branch i guess of what i do now
is
is writing about these things so i wrote
a big book on happiness well your first
book was called happy yeah and your
second book was called happy it's called
a little happier and it's literally just
a little version of
happy what surprised you in the research
of that book what
did you as you were discovering the
research you went huh no kidding i got
it all wrong
well actually what surprised me was that
it really resonated with me as i said i
was never
ambitious i studied law i was supposed
to be a lawyer you and me both
by the time i graduated i wasn't really
interested and i was already starting to
perform and that interested me more
so i kind of avoided the sort of
career path and felt a little bit like a
child in a world of grown-ups and that
feeling
accompanied me for a lo for a long time
then you start to feel like you've
um you must be doing something wrong
because everybody's
everybody's a grown up and you're not
and i think one of the things that the
stoics
so stoicism was a as i'm sure many of
your listeners will know is a 2 000 year
old
school of philosophy that was hugely
popular it started with the greeks and
it really exploded during the roman
times and it was the main kind of rival
as christianity sort of exploded
into the world so they had to the early
christians had to bring a lot of the
stoic ideas
on board themselves to win the stoics
over so for that reason
a lot of these stoic ideas are still
familiar with us nowadays
and it really leads into this idea of
what you choose to attach to and whether
you choose to
pay attention to what's within or what's
outside and where you kind of
hook your your ideas of happiness and i
found that actually
my sort of general lack of ambition and
preference to
well to just sort of think well this is
my life at the moment
as i'd like it to be rather than
fixating on something that is you know
kind of on the horizon
actually could be a perfectly
sensible and happy way of of being and i
suppose
as i read them it really resonated with
me how do we find happiness
in these times of awkwardness and stress
well again there's that problem of the
word being
a little easy to throw around as a noun
like it's the thing you can find
what the stoics presented which was a
really interesting thing is actually a
quite a specific way of approaching
something like happiness so they saw it
as an avoidance of unnecessary
disturbance
so an avoidance of kind of unnecessary
anxiety and this is an interesting idea
when
whoops that's exactly what we're living
in yeah yeah necessary disturbance
this idea has really stayed with us for
a long time so freud for example when
freud
you know created talking therapy
his model was not about making people
happy his aim was to restore
natural unhappiness as he called it life
is basically going to be unhappy a lot
of the time
but you don't want to be unnaturally
unhappy you just want to kind of you
know
get your levels of happiness and
unhappiness about right so
the stoic notion is about avoiding
unnecessary
disturbance as they call it so it's the
opposite
of the kind of classic modern
optimism model it's not pessimism at all
but it's it's a kind of
certain strategic pessimism i guess but
it is sort of the opposite so the model
is kind of this
if you try and control things that are
out of your control
you're obviously going to create all
sorts of needless anxiety
which you know makes sense so the only
things you can control
and therefore the only things to pay
attention to well what are they well
they are your thoughts and your actions
and really that's it and everything
outside of that
what other people do what other people
think outcomes
you know that you have no control over
everything else that's kind of in the
world
you can't control now the classic sort
of optimism model
sort of cheats you into telling you you
can if you set your goals enough if you
believe in yourself
enough if you do your vision board if
you whatever if you put this stuff
out in the universe that the universe
will provide
and that can be great and it can feel
great but the trouble is it's going to
let you down at some point and it
doesn't leave you with much other than a
it you do know that the title of my
podcast is is a bit of optimism right
so basically what you're saying is if
you come here you're going to be let
down
i think life is eventually one way or
the other takes us to difficult points
and if you have any philosophy or school
of thought it needs to help you in those
moments
what i actually like about that the
freud thing naturally unhappy yeah i
actually think i understand what he was
trying to say
which is it's actually not about being
naturally unhappy it's about a baseline
and the baseline should be relatively
low
in other words manage your expectations
you know if you're
19 years old and you're planning on
being a millionaire by the time you're
25
that's not entirely in your control it
may or may not happen
odds are not really but the expectation
is to enjoy what you have
rather than keep comparing and looking
what you don't have
i think that's what freud was trying to
say right well you're saying that the
basic state of being alive is your
caught between what you
instinctively want to do and what
society allows you to do so there's an
unavoidable
tension you know there's so yeah but the
same idea
has appeared with different philosophers
and psychologists throughout
history but i have an argument with the
stomachs which is that we have to
disconnect ourselves we can only control
what you know what we control to attach
ourselves to our reputations what the
world thinks of us
it's the same mistake that maslov made
because maslov's hierarchy of needs as
you know the baseline is
food and shelter and like three levels
up as human relationships
and i've never heard of anyone
committing suicide because they were
hungry we commit suicide because we're
lonely
and the mistake that maslov made is that
he only considered us as individuals and
as individuals his hierarchy is correct
unfortunately we are also every single
day
members of groups and this is the
paradox of being human that every day
we have to reconcile putting myself
first or putting the group first and
there's an entire school of thought that
says no no no
you have to take care of yourself first
because if you're not healthy you can't
help the group
and there's another entire school of
thought that says no no you have to help
the group first because if you don't
help them then they can't help you
when you're in need and you're both
right and you're both wrong it's a
paradox
and so maslov only got us half right and
the stoics
it's the same way it ignores that we're
social animals
that of course we care about what other
people think of us if you're in a
relationship
of course you care what the other person
thinks about you in fact you better care
what the other person thinks about you
so the question is is how do we take
what the stoics are telling us
and reconcile that and manage it with
the fact that we actually do have a
responsibility
in how we show up in other people's
lives how we talk to them and how we
treat them
and they have in ours i think you're
absolutely right and there are definite
i think edges
to stoic wisdom i think it holds that it
does hold up very well i think it's a
very
robust way of thinking but you're right
you are the right edges and most of
those edges do
come in when you look at you know they
didn't really have a lot to say about
love
and about feelings of community and so
on which is exactly this it's
all about developing a robust sense of
self so for that reason it kind of you
know it leans on that
side well i think it's very much about
seeing life as a journey it goes back to
the happiness right it's life is a
journey not as an event
that none of these things are events
they're moments in time they're
snapshots in the movie
but the movie's still ongoing yeah yeah
this is dr carso's work dr james carson
the infinite game
which is it's ever going and so this
idea that when something bad happens
saying
well this two will pass and by the way
that goes for things that are good as
well
yes of course this idea of this infinite
thinking this what you're talking about
as well
you know i think it keeps you humble
even when you're on top of the world
this too will pass
that's the idea that if the hero doesn't
die in the book then the author hasn't
finished the story
right it's the meander and i think it
also includes
legacy because we don't want our lives
to be that snapshot where we think this
is it
this is my life but rather we hope that
we can leave something behind
and outlive ourselves that we will be
remembered and i think
this is where the act of service comes
in that when you live a life
driven entirely by ambition and
self-interest
you may achieve all your goals debatable
whether you'll be happy or not once you
do
but you know you may achieve all your
goals you may achieve great wealth great
fame great success however you want to
define it
but you have weak relationships and when
you die you take none of it with you and
that's it it's over
and the question is what have you done
for others for example
we all have somebody from our childhood
a teacher who took a particular liking
to us or took us under their wing
and we can remember their names tell me
the name of one teacher that took a
liking to you
mr palastro yeah there you go mr
palastro right
now you've probably forgotten most of
the other teachers but you can remember
those ones
who remembered you and for him mr
palastro
he has done something to live on
infinitely he will live on
behind his own lifetime because you will
say i am who i am
today in part because of him that to me
is a way to live a life and you know one
thing that i sort of rail against is
this entire section on the bookshop
called self-help
and there's no section in the bookshop
called help others and we're all
obsessed with reading books so that we
can find
that elusive thing that thing called
happiness
but we're not reading a book about how
we can happy
that actually has an impact on the lives
of others well there's right there the
word self is another noun that should be
a verb
you know we self our notion of self is
something that is
fluid and it changes and it reaches out
and it extends
into the world through the tools that we
use and the relationships we're in the
idea that it's this sort of
unit we can pay the sort of attention to
that those self-help books suggest is
sort of wrong they all start with the
notion of the self that's very odd
it reminds me of um back to the question
of
finding happiness at this time you know
the kind of the
stoic approach which is to essentially
deal with your own stuff
and separate your center of gravity
bring it in and take it out of
the rest of the world and what's going
on there but there's another completely
opposed idea to that which i think is
just as important and you know the world
is complex and messy so we can dip into
stoicism and dip into things that are
completely opposite to it going back to
this idea that life is
ultimately going to be difficult at
times
when those times happen our tendency is
to feel
particularly if we're you know
subscribers to a heavily optimistic
model is that we've failed
and that we've sort of been let down or
whatever it is we tend to feel alone and
we feel fearful and we feel panicky
but i think what's interesting in those
moments is that because life is
centripetal it will
ultimately pull us to the center it will
pull us to these moments that those are
the moments when we're being shown
the actual weight of life we're being
shown in a strange way where we're most
alive
because we're not distracted by all the
things that are going on we've been
pulled to the center
so although we feel most alone we're
actually at the point that we share with
everybody we're actually strangely at
our most connected point with other
people
which allows us to lean into that
differently because we can then turn a
kind of a sadness which might be
inward directed and our sense of failure
outwards into a sort of a kind of a
melancholy maybe back this idea of
unnatural happiness a sense of you know
life life is difficult but we all share
in these things and
this feeling of isolation is actually
something that connects us weirdly to
other people even though at the moment
it wouldn't normally
feel like that and this whole lockdown
situation this pandemic is a
strangely literal demonstration of
exactly that it's a resource for us to
lean into the things that make us feel
most isolated tend to be the things that
make us
connect with other people this is
interesting you've given me a lot to
think about you know i absolutely love
this idea
of these quote unquote goals that we set
these abstract arbitrary
ill-defined goals like happiness success
you know relationship you used
relationship as well
as if there's something to achieve like
now that i've got the relationship i'm
good
and forgetting that all of these things
if anything
are actually starting points not ending
points that if you find the thing that
makes you happy now you have to do hard
work to maintain
if you find someone that you think you
can have a relationship with now you
have to do hard work to maintain
yeah that if you find success in
whatever form it takes
now you have to do the hard work and i
love the idea of seeing these things as
verbs as journeys as ongoing pursuits
but also that they're not end goals
they're actually starting points
they're relationships they're all in
themselves you know your relationship
with success and failure are just
yeah they're ongoing activities aren't
they how do you
compare them to your expectations how do
you compare events yeah you're expecting
i mean they're very active
complex messy things that we're making
choices about
all the time they are not these neat
nouns we only see them like that so that
we can
park them somewhere in our brain and not
be
challenged by what they demand from us
yeah
i have one more question for you yeah
just because i'm curious
tell me an early specific happy
childhood memory
getting a huge pile of paper my mom
brought back from work
like a ream of paper like 500 sheets or
whatever that is
and i used to love drawing and the
sheer excess of paper was
staggering to me and i would just i was
an only child at that age and i was just
drawing and scribbling and i don't think
i've ever had a gift that was
as exciting or experienced such a kind
of a
such a joy particularly as a kid it was
the
sheer creative sort of freedom i feel a
bit of that now when i'm painting and
you know there's like the blank canvas
and i got a day that's free to get on
with it i have a similar sort of thing
but that was a very focused i just
couldn't believe
the bliss of this big pile of
hundreds of sheets of black paper is
extraordinary i think it has nothing to
do with the drawing
it has to do with the amount of paper
that your mother gave you
if she'd given you one piece of paper
you would have had joy drawing one
drawing
she gave you five pieces of paper you
would have done five drawings and been
very very happy
but what she gave you was for a child an
infinite amount of paper
what she gave you was opportunity what
she gave you was runway
which he gave you was path and what you
learned at that young age is that it
took someone else
to open a path for you to give you an
opportunity to do the thing you love
and perhaps that's what you do in your
work
you show us a path to pursue the thing
we love
unencumbered by stress
narrative attachment and perhaps
in your work what you're attempting to
do is give us each
a ream of paper with infinite
possibility to do things that we love
i'll take it that's a life worth living
yep
that'd be nice yeah
i'm happy with that that's lovely can i
make one suggestion
go for it buy yourself a ream of paper
take the plastic off leave that ream of
paper on your desk and never use a sheet
of it
it's a reminder the reminder is that you
are to provide reams of paper for the
rest of us
nice well i really appreciate you taking
the time to happy with me
well it's been a pleasure nice talking
to you darren a real pleasure thank you
for having me on thank you so much
of course be well
[Music]
if you enjoyed this podcast and you'd
like to hear more please subscribe
wherever you like to listen to podcasts
until then take care of yourself take
care of each other